[Music]
well good evening welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight last week we broke the
story that CIA director and political
extremists John Brennan as well as other
Obama officials somehow retained their
security clearances long after leaving
their government jobs this allowed them
access to highly classified information
including leaks from former colleagues
who are still working in the Intel
agencies today the White House announced
it is seeking to revoke those clearances
we'll have more on that in just a moment
but first we finally have a copy of the
FISA warrant application that allowed
the Obama administration to spy on the
Trump campaign in 2016
that document is heavily redacted but
certain facts are clear the clearest of
all the Obama administration argued with
a straight face that Carter page was a
secret agent working for the Russians
this is absurd and yet it was widely
believed in Washington watch this there
was a very clear belief that Carter Page
was conspiring with Russia to in ways
that that were nefarious there was
overwhelming evidence to have probable
cause to do surveillance and Carter page
it would have been a dereliction of duty
for our FBI not to have sought a
surveillance warrant as you say it makes
a compelling case that there is probable
cause to believe that Carter Paige was
acting as an agent of a foreign power a
compelling case really well if it's so
compelling why aren't we hearing that
case in court a Carter pages treason
trial
well because it's total nonsense it's a
bad joke the FISA application doesn't
even begin to prove that Carter Paige
betrayed his country in any way but the
application does prove other things we
now know for example conclusively that
the discredited steel dossier was
central to the Obama administration's
request to spy on the Trump campaign
former FBI director Jim Comey has
publicly denied that perhaps assuming
the actual request would never be
released Comey claimed that the dossier
was not a significant part of the
government's request and that turns out
to be a lie not only did the Obama
administration used
Steele dossier is the basis of its
spying request it appears the FBI did
essentially nothing to verify the claims
of the dossier despite the fact they
knew it was a partisan document paid for
by political operatives the Hillary
Clinton campaign and the DNC it was too
good to check apparently
instead of sending its own agents to run
down the facts which of course it could
have done in fact it exists to do the
FBI instead cited a Yahoo News article
to prove that the dossier was reliable
the only problem with that the yahoo
piece was itself based on leaked
information from steal you'd have to be
utterly incompetent to do something like
that or totally dishonest